[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hi.
Welcome to Radcliffe.
My name is John Huth.
And I'm a member of the ventures
faculty for the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced
Study hosting this lecture
in the lecture series.
So today, we're honored to
have Keith Ellenbogen, who
is going to talk to us
about ocean photography,
and in particular, the linkage
to inspiring conservation.
He is a highly acclaimed
professional photographer
who got his MFA from the
Parsons School of Design.
He has a huge number of awards.
So I'm not a big believer
in long introductions.
But suffice to say that he does.
The most recent endeavor,
that I'm aware of,
was he spent time at
the Doc Edgerton Center
for High Speed Imaging at MIT.
For those of you who aren't
familiar with Doc Edgerton,
he was one of the
people who pioneered
this idea of
high-speed photography,
like you can see a bullet going
through an apple, for example.
There are many iconic
photographs up there.
And he was working with a
physics professor, Allan Adams,
on high-speed photography
with an underwater focus.
And because I'm a fan
of fluid dynamics,
I'm hoping I'll see one
photograph on the topic.
So the format is for the talk.
At the end, the questions
will be open to the audience.
And we'll take them
as long as we can.
So Keith.
- Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello.
Is this-- can you all hear me?
I'd like to thank you, John,
and the Radcliffe Institute
for having me here.
It's really very nice.
So welcome.
Today, I'd like to talk
to you about taking you
all on a journey beneath the
ocean into an underwater world.
We're a visual culture.
And photography has the power
to captivate our attention
and spark conservation.
This is a picture
of a barrier reef
taken within the remote
Tortola Islands in Fiji.
On this assignment, I
was fortunate to have
eight hours of flight
time on a helicopter,
and was able to capture what
a barrier reef looks like,
and how the barrier reef absorbs
the energy of the ocean waves
from the island itself.
But it's the underwater
images that are not easily
seen by people around the world
that I'm interested in sharing
with you today.
So I'd like to take you all
on a journey underwater,
and on expeditions
around the world.
All right, so first,
what is it like
to travel with me
on an assignment?
You need a lot of equipment,
both photography equipment,
underwater equipment,
housing equipment, dive gear.
And then you need redundant
systems for everything.
Once you travel to these
remote parts of the world,
it's what you bring
is what you have.
So you need all of it with you.
And once you get used to
having stuff, you want more.
So here's what it looks
like when I'm on a boat
and the seas are calm.
I use, basically,
a Canon 5D Mark
II, which is a DSLR camera.
So I have adjustable
lenses and full control
over all of the equipment.
I also use an CNC
underwater housing,
which basically means that the
camera is sealed in a housing.
And I have full control.
And their two YS-250
strobes-- which means I
can control all the light
and the camera underwater.
And so that's very important
in the art of photography,
in terms of capturing
the image that you're
interested in taking.
So underwater
photography has all sorts
of challenges and problems.
First of all,
you're under water.
So you have limited
time, air, depth,
and you have to
find the animals.
This picture was taken
of me just the other day
on an assignment in Belize
photographing Nassau groupers.
I'm at 130 or 140
feet here of water.
And so you have a very
short amount of time
to see and find
what you want to do.
But why I like
this picture is it
was filmed by someone else
using a little GoPro camera.
And what it caught was
my strobes going off
as I'm taking a picture.
And what this shows is how you
illuminate an area in front
of you to capture an image.
And I want to really highlight
that all of photography
is about finding
the right light,
and capturing light
in a lot of ways.
And so one of the things
that's really important
is controlling where
the light will be,
and what you're photographing.
So when people think of
a coral reef, or reefs
around the world,
what they think of
is lots of fish, pretty
colors, and taking them.
And so I want to
describe a little bit
about what it means to be
a photographer before we
go forward.
And here you can see that
the images you want to see
is all the little
fish coming at you.
It's always fun when they're
facing you, rather than facing
away.
And in order to
have this, the fish
are swimming in-- there's
a strong ebb of a current
that's moving, really, actually,
quite pulsing fairly strong.
And so I'm swimming
inverted to the current
holding my breath-- well,
sort of not really breathing
here-- stabilizing while they
ebb and flow into a photograph.
Because you want
to fill the blue
with this beautiful
complementary color
of the orange.
In underwater
photography, the object
is to be close to your subject.
On land, you can be far.
You can have telephoto lenses.
You can sit and wait.
But in an underwater
environment,
we need to be close
to what we're seeing.
And so when I say
close, it's best
when they're within 6 inches
to a couple of feet away.
Less over 6 feet starts
to be more difficult.
So I thought I would just start
with what-- everyone always
assumes I just make it to a
place and I take some pictures.
But I wanted to sort
of highlight, to start,
what it means to take a picture.
This is in Indonesia
in Raja Ampat.
And these are karst
islands, which means
they are limestone islands.
And they have an
overshadow here.
But we want to look under water.
And this is what I
want to do is take
a picture of the
underwater environment.
And really, what I want to show
are three levels of something.
One, corals to the
island, which you
can see here with the black.
And then up in the top right
corner, you can see the trees
and through to the sky.
And what I noticed
was-- and you can see
there's a little silver part in
the center where the black is.
It's sort of a just
fortuitous moment
where there were [INAUDIBLE]
blenny that were spawning.
And there were all the
little juveniles were there.
And I saw them swim
in big numbers.
And what I didn't like
about this picture
was the black of
the entire island.
But it's what I saw.
And so when you
wait for photography
and are patient,
what you end up is
being able to compose
an image much the way
you preconceived it
in your own mind,
and then allow that
picture to come
to life through being prepared
for moments with photography.
Here's just another
example of in the Amazon.
This was taken
with-- of a pink--
this is a river dolphin
down in the Amazon.
And this was taken with a GoPro.
And under normal circumstances,
I would have said it was OK.
But if you want, what you
can do is control the light,
so it has a more
angelic feeling that
really is representative of the
environment that we're seeing.
And so I want to
just highlight that,
when you're seeing
these pictures,
they're taken with a lot of
intent for what I want to use,
and controlling the camera
and the light in such a way
as to make the image what
I feel is compelling,
or my vision of them.
So how do you capture some
of these kind of images?
I can only start by saying
patience and more patience.
This is what I would
say is maybe my best
bird shot I ever have taken.
And it was a moment
where I was in Mexico.
The weather was really terrible.
And we were doing a project
on local communities
and small-scale fisheries.
And I noticed that
these birds were
diving in the same area
almost every day all the time.
And when the weather was bad,
and we were just stopped,
and I just was observing this.
And then after I got my
shots for the assignment,
I had a day and a half left.
I said to myself, you know,
I'm just going to try for this.
And this is the kind of shot
that you don't do anything else
other than set up for one shot.
I was just prepared
for this only shot.
I stood in an area.
And I waited.
And when I say I
waited, I wasn't
just like sitting there
talking to myself.
I was waiting, half of an
eye in the water, half an eye
looking at the birds, strobe in,
strobe out, and just waiting.
And all of the sudden,
they would do it.
And I had varying
forms of success,
but not the success I wanted.
And then all of the
sudden, it came through.
And it landed.
And when a bird like this
flies, they're really fast.
And then they stall out
right in front of you
and virtually stop.
It's absolutely incredible.
And then it flies again.
It can't land in the water.
If it were to land in the
water, it would drown.
And so at this very
moment, I pull the trigger.
And I looked at my
assistant behind me.
And I said, I think
I might have got it.
I was so nervous.
Anyway I did look.
And then I rushed
back to the place,
and opened it up
to see how it goes.
Here's an example of river
herring of a photograph where
you're going to see the animal.
They're there.
But you want to control
the environment.
Because what was so
interesting, to me,
is the turbulence in
there of the water moving.
And what I wanted to
photograph was each bubble
moving, and to show
the rapidness of it,
and stopping that
motion of each bubble,
so the thing was
totally frozen, so you
get a real strong
feeling of motion moving
in a very strong current.
Sometimes, you end
up with moments
that are just by chance
you happen to find them.
This is a jellyfish.
And if you look
inside the technicals,
you can see all these
little juvenile fish
that are swimming in there.
And when I noticed it, what I
wanted to do is drift with it,
and create a composition.
So I'm looking up
at the jellyfish.
And through what's
the texture is
the sky is the water surface.
And then the white is a
little bit of the sky--
so to create a
composition, as well,
and to wait for the jellyfish
to move in such a way
as that you can see the fish.
In Palau, these are
humphead wrasse.
They're big.
They're like 5 feet long.
This is one of the few
places in the world where
you can see them.
And they'll actually come in
and integrate close with you.
And so this is an
endangered species,
of which it was a
picture that was
used by Canon to help support
wildlife, as Canon sees it.
And it's to help endangered
species get awareness,
and to use photography in a
way to engage with an animal.
And only when they
come up close--
and again, a lot of
underwater photography
is that sort of
vision or ability
to get close to an animal.
Here are a few other
moments, in terms of where--
this is a story of aggregating,
mating, tiger grouper.
And they've changed their
entire coloration here.
And it's like a mirror
in a reflection.
Now I knew they would do
this kind of behavior.
I wasn't sure if they would
do it while I was there.
And what they do is they
just stare at each other
for a brief moment.
And then they don't have
a violent interaction.
But it's just a showdown.
It's a really
extraordinary thing.
And it's like a reflection
in the sea of each other.
And you only see this
coloration for a very short time
when they're during
the spawning season.
And sometimes in
photography, you
see that animals are equally as
intelligent as we think we are.
And in the water
here in photography,
one of the challenges
is, how do you actually
photograph something?
And what are the modes that
make photography complicated?
And I noticed that this sea lion
kept spinning me into the sun,
so that it was
constantly backlit.
And I would keep trying to
do the same tricks where
I would move away and
it would look at me.
But it didn't.
And eventually, one
of the other sea lions
sort of blocked the light.
And it sort of engaged in a way.
And you realize that they are
very aware of the elements
as well as I'm aware of.
So this you wouldn't notice
it, but this is probably
one of the hardest
pictures I've taken.
This is a purple-eyed
dwarf goby.
It's teeny.
It was taken in Fiji.
And it was just drifting
off of the edge of water
of the shelf of the reef.
And why it's so difficult is
because it's-- this was taken
at the macro lens.
And what you want
to do is in this--
it was taken in daylight.
And the black is the result
of how you set the camera, so
that you don't have that.
And what you want
is a strong focus
one to one on the one animal.
And then you want
to blur everything
else in the background,
and keep things in line.
But when you're drifting,
it's really hard to do.
And so no one believes me that
I practice and control my body,
my movement, and my strength.
And that's the kind of
image that was really hard,
and where you're focusing.
You ever focus really
close, and it's
hard to keep track of things?
That's what this
was an exercise in.
But they don't move very
much, so that was helpful.
So I'd like to take you
now on a little journey all
the way around the world
to the Phoenix Islands.
This is a place in
between Fiji and Hawaii.
And you can see there's a very
small dot in the very center
there.
That's where we were.
It was an assignment with
a New England Aquarium
and partners with
Conservation International.
And there was scientists from
Woods Hole, as well there.
And so in this place, this was
one of those assignments where
it was a--
it's become one of the
largest marine protected areas
and no-take zones.
The aquarium is doing
tremendous work,
in terms of
conservation efforts,
studying about this
place, and conserving it.
And what you get to see in here
are juvenile black-tip reef
sharks that use the
little lagoon as a place
to grow up and
mature a little bit.
You see beautiful
coral reefs here.
This is a place that
only few have been to.
And again, the sharks peruse
the shelf of the outer reef,
just slowly looking.
As we begin to look into the
reef, into some of the things,
you see some small details.
You can see all
three little shrimp--
they're sort of
translucent-- hiding
in there, to various
crabs that are there.
And here's what some of
the scientists were doing.
They were taking
large core samples,
because these corals
grew very, very large.
They're in pristine waters.
They're relatively
not interfered
with too many
human interactions.
And so they take these
large coral samples.
And they look at ocean
acidification temperature,
and a whole bunch of other
things back here in Boston.
And then they'll write
up papers, and have
a whole bunch of publications.
But what makes conservation,
and photography,
and integrating the
two so wonderful.
To me, it was a
moment here-- where
this is President Tong
of the Kiribati Islands
with John Kerry
in the background.
And what the New England
Aquarium has been doing
is they've been
working with them.
And he gave a presentation that
was asked for on large oceans,
on becoming marine
protected areas.
And he used many of
the pictures that I
had taken from this assignment.
Albeit, there aren't
many photographers
who have been there.
But he did use
them, nonetheless.
And as a way to show what
it's like to be in a place,
because it's hard to communicate
what visuals are of a place
without actually seeing them.
And it's that complementary
interaction between scientists
and between photographers
that I think
engage the community about
a place, and make people
feel connected to it.
On an assignment to
the Turtle Islands,
which is in the
Philippines and Malaysia--
it's an assignment about
bilateral countries working
together.
In this one particular area,
there's green sea turtles.
And worldwide, their populations
are really endangered.
But in this one area, there
are really lots of them
all over the place.
And every morning, you would see
sea turtles just walking up--
you wouldn't see sea turtles.
You'd see the remnants
of sea turtles there.
They protected the areas.
And this is how they
would be marked.
And every day, we looked
for mating sea turtles.
And for the three
weeks I was there,
we really didn't see them,
to be honest with you.
And the only way I was
able to see them was--
finally, I was
sort of frustrated
that we weren't seeing them.
We couldn't cover enough ground.
They weren't coming
up to the surface.
So I was towed behind a boat
like a water skier, but slowly,
and just towed over
long distances.
And when I saw it finally, I
would break off with my camera,
and snorkel, and free dive
with these for a while.
And that's how I
would spend time.
And they can easily swim away.
But they decided
to stay with you.
I think they must have
enjoyed the experience.
Anyway, those are
mating sea turtles.
And this is one of those
assignments where there really
aren't enough hours in a day.
During the day, you're
looking for sea turtles,
and other coral reefs,
and animals in the reef.
And at night is when they do
all the laying of the eggs.
And so basically, my day
would start really early.
And at night, when here
they would lay their eggs--
and you would see, again,
the slow motion of the image.
You would see the eggs
that are laid here.
And different approaches,
in the Philippines,
they let the turtles
lay the eggs.
And as the turtles laid
them, they left them there.
But in Malaysia,
they took the eggs.
And they put them into
containers at different depths
so that the males became males
and females became females.
And then they took
the hatchlings
and released them
into the ocean.
Two different approaches.
Both seemed to be working.
You ever wonder
what it's like to be
a sea turtle when they first
go out at 5:00 in the morning?
Here's the little
wave that it sees.
And when you're underwater,
this is what it looks like.
And there he is on
his little swim.
Sometimes, nature just finds and
adapts to different conditions.
And so here is a bottle
cap that a crab found.
And I thought I would
just share a little story
of what happens
on an assignment,
and why you need
so much equipment.
This harmless little cord
here, I thought, got pinched.
And when I was underwater taking
pictures, all of the sudden,
my strobes did travel.
It didn't flash.
And I said to myself, well,
maybe I've been tired.
I've been working
since midnight.
I'm up at 5:00
o'clock every morning.
It's been three weeks like this.
Maybe I messed up.
Anyway, I bring it back.
And I put it back.
And I noticed a second
camera, same problem.
Both cameras don't work.
And I show it to
one of the guys.
And he says to me, you
know what happened?
I was like, no.
A mouse came and ate only
the plastic of my cords,
and wrecked all of them.
Now I only had two left.
And I'm heading on an assignment
for another three weeks.
I have to take a day from
where I was-- because you
had to only get there by boat.
There's no internet,
no cell phones,
no anything-- a day
boat ride to go,
all the fuel I had to burn
to go to land, send an email.
I'm embarrassed to fess this up.
But I did have to
email my mother
to help coordinate with everyone
while I was off the grid
how to get two more
for the next one,
because you don't want to
be without the appropriate
equipment.
And one other
conservation story that I
think is really meaningful
is the Atlantic bluefin tuna.
These ones, every year, go on an
annual migration to reproduce.
And you can see
them in big numbers.
And what they do was,
in the Mediterranean Sea
where you could see eye-to-eye,
water-to-water, in one area
when they found the tuna, you
could see-- all those blips
or dots on the boat are
where the fishing boats
are going to catch the tuna.
And I can tell you that,
in one month of fishing,
that are licensed
for legal fishing,
they caught the
quota in one day,
to give you a sense of how much
scale that they're catching.
It's legal.
It's a good way to do it.
But then it's the next
days that we're becoming
the problems of the fishing.
And what they would do is they
would use these purse seiner
fishing techniques.
They would swim out.
They would scoop
up all the tuna.
They had planes overhead
to spot them-- what
they're not supposed to do.
They threw food in
the water-- what
they're not supposed to do.
They did everything
They catch all of them.
And they round them up.
And then they put them
in these giant cages.
And you can see the tugboat
going through through the scale
of the purse seiner nets.
And to give you
a sense of scale,
the people in the foreground.
I like this.
And what we did is
we would dive in.
And sometimes, we would
see them in the water.
And sometimes, we would see
them in the purse sein nets.
And they were an
incredible animal.
I've never been next
to a fish like this.
And to give you a sense of
what the power of it is,
is when it swam by you, it was
like being in a concert where
you feel the ripple of a
bass going through your chest
as you move back from pure power
of a fish just moving on you.
When we did these
very quick dives in,
they would basically drive the
Zodiac, a little quick boat.
He'd go, you have two minutes
to get in the water and get out.
Because the fishermen
were not exactly happy
we were doing this all the time.
This is how the sea
looks when it looks
like you're going down on it.
It's just as large of
a net as you can be.
And when you drop down
to about 150 or 160 feet,
this is looking back
up to try and give
a scale of how large
these nets are.
They're actually quite
spacious in there.
And the fish aren't-- you're
not like packed in like a tiny
little net.
And this is the
picture, for me, that's
been the most widely used
of all my photographs.
This picture is of the tuna.
You can see how
reflective they are,
which is what makes them
so hard to photograph.
And what makes it
so proud for me
is it was used the picture
to represent the species when
it was going up for a vote
is an endangered animal.
Unfortunately, many countries
abstained from that vote.
So it didn't go through.
But it still feels
very proud to me
that they use this photo
to represent its species.
And we spent three months.
And I only had three or
four days of opportunities
really seeing the tuna.
So I thought I would just
transition for a little bit
into the art of
photography, and just
show some things that I thought
were just really beautiful.
Because I feel nature is so
spectacular in many ways.
This is in Jellyfish
Lake in Raja Ampat.
Here, you can start
to see texture.
These are juvenile.
These are eggs of a clownfish.
And you can see, they're
still in the case.
And all the dots are
little eye pupils.
And I think it's for, if
you're a pinhole photography,
there's a certain size that
the eye has to be for it
to actually see certain things.
So I believe they are
oversized eyes for really
such a small creature.
Here's what polyps look like
when they're open at night.
Some of what feels like a
painterly side of a clam.
And you can see on
the very bottom,
while it may look like a
simple and a static picture,
they're actually fairly quick to
close if there's any movement.
They have a lot of eyes.
On the very top
and on the bottom,
you can see little
like highlights.
It almost looks
white on the screen.
Those are all eyes all
around the shell of this.
Just some of the movements.
What's interesting to me
about nature in many ways
is that color becomes a thing.
We often just say pink,
or yellow, or red.
But texture, really--
there's a strong gradation,
in terms of coloration.
Using flatness where they're
all on the same plane
and finding ones
so that repetition
becomes interesting--
sometimes, it's
about the creatures
that blend into this, of
which, one, you can see him
in the center there.
It's a crab with its eye facing
to the left, towards this way.
It's a pygmy
seahorse blending in.
And some little motion
of a tiny clinoid
as it starts to crawl
through an anemone.
And lastly, when you want
to flatten out an image so
that it becomes flat
with the sea around it,
and just the texture of it
shows, this is what, to me,
coloration does.
It so extraordinary
to look at why
there would be those greens and
purples and tones right there.
So with all the travel
around the world,
let me just say that the most
extraordinary places I've ever
been are Boston and New York.
And no one ever believes
me on these things.
So I'm going to
take you back here
to show why this
place is so great.
So this, first of all, is--
we might as well
start with sharks.
Because, why not?
This is a project that
I was working with.
This is Greg Skomal.
He's tagging a tiger shark.
This is in New York.
And basically, what
they're studying or looking
at are, when they tag sharks,
is to understand the behavior.
Where are they moving?
How do they move through
the open sea here?
And so they've caught it.
And then they're putting
a tag on its dorsal fin.
This is one way of doing
it where it's in the water.
A second way is when
they lift the shark out.
This is a mako shark.
These guys always have a
very ferocious looking eye,
as you can see right there.
And when they
encounter you, they
are very skittish and erratic.
Anyway, they're putting
a tag on both of these.
You can see how rough
the sea was that day,
that I'm bobbing in the sea
just over and over again
waiting for this.
Here's what happens when a tiger
shark-- when they release it,
you can see the tag on it.
And then in real time, they
can update and understand
where it's going
around the area.
And some of the sharks that
I've worked on in New York,
they've been tagged all the
way down to North Carolina,
and came back up in the
same season, which is pretty
dramatic swimming distance.
And here's what happens
when you take a picture,
and you're a little
bit too close--
or I didn't mean
to be this close.
And that's the tiger shark.
Although, in this case,
it was a juvenile.
So it's all good.
All right, this is with Greg.
I'm in the air.
Greg is in the
pulpit on the front.
And there's a great white shark.
This is what you see a
lot of in the Cape now.
And here's why you're
seeing them all.
Here are all the seals.
And so just a short hop,
skip, and a jump from Chatham
is to New York, which is
where I live in Brooklyn.
And this is a project that I've
now been spending the last four
years taking pictures to create
awareness with the New York
aquarium and the Wildlife
Conservation Society
to create awareness about
underwater wildlife of New
York.
It's probably the hardest
place I photographed,
because the conditions are
much more challenging here.
One, the animals are
migrating through.
In most places
around the world, you
know it's relative, right
time of year, certainly,
you can put yourself
in certain situations.
But in this, it's
just open water.
You have no way of knowing
when or where something
is going to be.
And this is Long Island in
the Hamptons looking east
towards Montauk.
And on the right is
the Atlantic Ocean.
And from the air looking down,
we have very diverse habitat.
Here's Great South Bay, which
is a seagrass and wetlands.
And within this habitat, you
see extraordinary animals,
such as pipe fish.
We see bluefish.
These guys, in May, come
in in very cold water,
in very shallow
water, buzzing by.
They're extraordinarily fast.
And they whip right by.
It's a really
incredible experience.
We have scallops with all those
beautiful little blue eyes.
And don't be mistaken.
They're quite fast.
And if they see you coming, they
skedaddle away really quick.
We have nudibranchs.
Here it is.
You can see his dot of
his eye in the center.
And the green in the background
is the algae that it's next to.
OK, here's the challenge of
diving in New York and Boston.
The visibility isn't that great.
And the reason it
isn't that great
is not because it's
pollution, but rather
because it's
nutrient-rich water.
And it's all the plankton,
all the algae in the water.
All the food source
in the water is
what makes all these animals
come rushing in here,
and why it's so rich to see
photographically, visually,
and from an animal's
perspective.
But this is a bait
ball of bunker.
This is what it looks
like underwater.
Now it's hard to see here.
And they're baited
up fairly tight.
Now I hope to see
this more and more.
This is a moment.
They don't ball up this
tight all the time.
There must be a giant
thresher underneath them deep
balling them up in this way.
And one day, it will come
up for me through there.
And here's what else
we have are wrecks,
lots of wrecks in New York.
And on these wrecks,
we have conger eels.
We have sea bass--
yeah, sorry about that--
and sort of the gradients
of blue mussels.
We have hydroids.
And then here we had mackerel.
And this is a night I was
looking for, actually, squid.
But the mackerel came
instead of the squid.
And at night while I
was going for them,
I decided to photograph
the mackerel instead.
One baby squid came up.
And all of the sudden,
the mackerel pegged it.
And we never saw
another squid again.
But here's what happens
on another day when
a squid actually comes.
Now this squid didn't actually
attack me or anything.
It's on the dome, just
grabbing on a hold of my dome,
of the round part of the dome.
And this is a moment, for
a photographer, that's
like a panic-stricken moment.
One, do I try for the photo?
Or two, do I worry
that it's going
to use its little teeth
right there to bite my dome,
and flood my camera?
Anyway, I quickly adjusted
the lights, took one picture,
and gave him a little nudge.
And off he went.
In the Hudson Canyon, 100
miles off of Long Island,
is a flying fish.
And then strange
sooty shearwaters,
as they look at
you, and must say,
like, what are you
doing underwater here?
But you can just see them.
They dive underwater.
They're really incredible.
We have extraordinary
animals that look ungainly.
And they're slow-moving,
like Mola mola here.
But they're really fast.
Don't be surprised.
And the people who have seen
them-- although, I have not
seen it-- jump out of the
water, and just fully launch
their body out of the water.
They're often very
curious, and will come up
to people who are snorkeling.
And here's what I think is
the most beautiful shark out
of all the sharks
that I've encountered,
which is the blue shark.
When we start to get really
close to these sharks,
and they come right up
within inches of the lens,
you can see all the detail
of how it can sense around.
So it doesn't just use
its visuals of its eyes.
But also, is using these
other senses much like a radar
to be able to detect, probably,
lots of things around.
We have sea turtles
that are endangered,
endangered loggerhead
sea turtle.
And unfortunately, there are
many problems in the sea,
as well.
Here are sharks that have
been entangled in nets,
others from fishermen,
who let them go.
But mostly, I want
to just highlight
the things that are really
extraordinary under there,
which are mahi-mahi.
And while I've been
looking for a mako,
and haven't seen a mako
the way I want to see it,
we do have drifting seahorses.
And this one is just
hiding, and hanging out
with a little grain of
seaweed 20 miles off
of the coast of Long Island.
And lastly, we
have a man o' war.
You don't want to touch these.
But those two fish
are man o' war fish.
And the amazing thing about this
is on the one day of the sea,
it just stopped.
The wind just paused.
And when it pauses like that,
you can see through the water.
And this is taken from a boat
as we positioned ourselves.
And so it's really just a matter
of time on the sea for that.
One of the extraordinary
things in New York
is these ancient mariners,
or horseshoe crabs.
And every year, they
have an annual migration.
And on this migration, which is
really important for seabirds
to come through.
They're dependent on the eggs
from these horseshoe crabs.
And here, you can see them.
And then here, you
would see that they're
mating and reproducing.
This is taken under a full
picture of a moon at night.
They come in by the thousands.
And in parallel, the
red knot sea birds
come in by the thousands.
And this is extremely important.
This happens in Cape
May, New Jersey.
And if the horseshoe
crabs are not there,
the red knots would
not be able to make
their journey all the way
up north through to Canada.
And because I work with Central
Park Conservancy sometimes,
you need to be able to show
the plaza in the background.
One of the turtles--
it probably was
released by someone who bought
one that didn't want it.
But nonetheless, an
inspiring picture
that was sort of an
idea that captured
from other
photographers, who have
done only surface-level
photographs of wildlife
in the park pond.
So I'd like to jump to a little
bit of high-speed photography,
and to show you a little bit
about a few different things.
So when taking high-speed
photography, normally,
you shoot cameras that
have about 1,000 frames--
well, excuse me.
Let me back up for one second.
First of all, in
high-speed photography,
you need a lot of light.
A normal camera shoots
about 30 frames per second--
video TV, for the most
part, 30 frames per second.
If you want to use a camera
and it says high speed,
usually it's 60
frames per second.
That's not a hard rule.
But on most cameras, it's
60 frames per second.
Sometimes, it jumps up
to 240 frames per second.
And they make it smaller.
The cameras that I'm using
are up to 1,000 frames,
maybe 10,000 frames per second.
And we did-- later, but I
don't have it here today--
we used one of the
world's fastest cameras
that was doing 10 million
frames of second on a project
with the Museum of Science
to look at lightning
as it sparks and
generates movement.
But what we're
interested in here
is how things move, and sort
of that invisible, balletic
movement.
And this is what it looks
like to start to shoot
with these kind of cameras.
And this is a project that is
with a good friend of mine,
Allan Adams, who's a physicist.
It's with Jim Bales,
who works as Assistant
Director of the Edgerton
Center, and has just been
a joy of a project to work on.
And so I thought
what I would show
you is what you
won't expect to see,
something that is
slow moving that
looks really cool
under high speed.
It's 1,000 frames per second.
It's about 20 times slower
than what your eye sees.
And what this is a jellyfish.
And you can just begin to
see all the subtle detail
in movement, which to me
looks like just a water, just
so beautiful.
So the way this plays is it
would play back 30 frames
per second-- just to
give you a sense of it--
over 20 times slower.
So you captured
that many frames.
And it plays it really slow.
And don't be mistaken of it
looking static and still.
In photographing this, you can
see there's like a white dot.
I'm moving the
camera and panning up
with this at the same speed
of the jellyfish moving.
So it gives the illusion
of stability and stable.
But if I just left
the camera, it
would be out of frame
[SNAPS] like this.
And you wouldn't have
the shot long enough.
The other technology
that we've been working
on a lot, which is looking
at 360 degree cameras,
and how to understand how things
move in spherical dimensions.
Now normally, with the camera,
I'm shooting in one dimension.
But learning how to
shoot in all around you
is a whole different world.
And so in order to show you
what this experience looked
like-- again, this is
collaboration with Allan.
This is working with
MIT, a collaboration
with the Museum of Science
and their planetarium
to help do this.
I went into the
giant ocean tank,
and thought I would
share with you what
it looks like to dive
in the giant ocean tank
from 360 point of view.
Now you can see me
very faintly, like you
would flatten the Earth out
if you looked at it unraveled.
I'm all the way on the left.
And I'm all the
way on the right.
I'm in the worst possible spot.
And you can see the multiple
cameras moving around.
And I really like this for
the artistic interpretation
of how we view ourselves.
And you can see that
we're feeding the fish.
And I'm inside the tank.
Now the experience
that you will see--
I have to pause
and jump over here.
This is me here.
Now I'm just going to
turn around a little bit,
and show you what it feels like
to be in the giant ocean tank.
And if you ever wonder, well,
what's happening up here,
we can see up here too.
And so it gives you
a full frame of way
to do this, to experience
more than one perspective.
And at some levels, it's
a little nauseating.
And in other ways,
it's really great.
But it's in its infancy.
And you can see that, with
my hand in the bottom left,
that it sort of looks
like it's missing.
This is where the stitching
overlap isn't perfect yet.
You can see that I'm
not holding any item.
But really, I'm holding the
camera as we're doing this.
And there's a pole
there that is invisible.
And if you're wondering where
all that food is coming from,
you need only turn
the camera around
to see that he's
feeding over here.
And if you want to look up, then
he must be around somewhere.
Or maybe it just happened.
Oh, there's the-- oh, just
watch this swim around.
I do like this one part here.
We'll go the other way.
I'll straighten you guys out.
I'll say this, that one
of the challenges of using
this kind of equipment,
it's been-- first of all,
there are many challenges
along the line.
Mostly, light is a big factor
on the underwater 360 modes.
But the one other real
challenge of doing this
is learning how to
view something in a way
where not all sides are
as interesting as others--
and so oftener not,
our perspective.
And in a world that
we really live in,
we really don't look around
us all the time so crazily.
And the camera sort
of begins to give us
that perspective of not
sure where our point of view
might be.
But it is a really fun
and interesting space.
And I think the underwater
world is a great place
to take people into a
world where we're totally
immersed in a situation.
And the Dome in the
Planetarium was particularly
enjoyable to do this.
This a arowana.
It's in the Amazon.
This is all taken at the New
England Aquarium through glass.
You can see a small little
cricket up on the top.
OK, you see it accelerate
through, and land down.
Shooting these at the
high speed has been--
it's actually the
joy of what we're
working on now more and more.
And I think the goal
is to how to get this
into an underwater
environment, how
to push ourselves to be
able to capture faster
speeds, or slower speeds.
And the way you take these
pictures in high speed,
because you can't react
fast enough all the time,
you said it to take
a picture a second.
It's constantly recording.
And when you
capture the shot, it
records for maybe a second or
two before or after the image
that is taken.
So you're able to guarantee
that you capture that moment.
And then you look back
at it and watch it.
And this whole process of
each shot that you take
can be anything from 10
minutes to 20 minutes
to watch and render to even
see if you got something.
So the process of really
capturing these over and over
again is quite
difficult and slow.
I might not have it on here.
I'll show you the lightning,
if you want to see that.
All right, this is taken
with a still camera.
This is a project that I
was done with Don Campbell
back there, as well, Allan
Adams, the Museum of Science.
And what we wanted to do is
photograph how lightning moves.
And so first, the way
we did this was we
looked at, how do you
do it with a camera?
And so you want to
open the shutter.
And you take it over
a long exposure here.
And you capture the light
moving back and forth.
And this was an extremely
wonderful experience.
So then I said, OK,
well, we'll go down.
We'll use a fast camera.
And they said, well,
what can you get?
And I said, well, we
can get a camera that's
capable of 100,000
frames per second.
So I went in there.
I was thinking, oh, my god,
100,000 frames per second.
We're going to get a great shot.
And I'll be very happy.
We go down.
We start taking the pictures.
And we use the camera.
And it sparks.
And we don't really
get anything.
And I'm like, oh, my god.
And I think Allan probably
knew deep down inside
I wasn't going to get anything.
But I don't think he
wanted to tell me,
just because he was
giving me a hard time.
Anyway, so the
next thing I know,
we don't get anything-- no
better than a standard camera.
Turns out that the lightning
is moving way faster
than a camera that's capable
of 100,000 frames per second.
I was better just
opening the shutter.
So I thought we would
be in difficult.
So we wrote and pitched
an idea to [INAUDIBLE]
to ask if they would be
willing to work with us,
and to come down to
lend us a camera that
was capable of shooting at
10 million frames per second.
And would they work
with us on this project?
So he flew in from California.
And we all set out to do this.
We set up.
Don was really helpful.
He made a trip wire that
would send the time,
so that we could
trigger this thing.
Because your reaction
is nowhere near fast
enough to capture these images
without some sort of device to
do this.
And so what you saw here,
this is at 10 million frames
per second.
And what we discovered
here is here
you can see the
spark of lightning
right here in the center.
And what you would see is it
grow out, and out, and out.
To give you a sense of what that
is, that was about 20 frames.
20 frames of 10 million
frames per second
is about the speed of what
we had here to capture this.
Well, that was the lightning.
Sorry about this.
But this as the superhero
of all superheroes.
This is a poison-arrow
dart frog as it climbs
at about 800 frames per second.
So what we did was this was shot
at the New England Aquarium.
We just misted up though
the glass in the front.
And then he climbed up.
And you can see, it's
totally incredible.
He would just grab a
hold, and could literally
climb a vertical surface.
These things are
absolutely incredible.
And you can see him breathing.
And this is the joy of
high-speed photography,
in that the slowness is
really wonderful of it.
He does jump, though.
There's one other shark
on I wanted to show you.
Maybe I'll take questions
while I look for this one.
I better take questions
while I look for that.
- Well, let's thank
the speaker, actually.
- Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- With all the predatory
fish and animals in the sea,
I was wondering--
because I had a
brother who surfed
from Ogunquit to New Jersey--
are they dangerous for
people who are surfing,
or in the water?
- The sharks?
- Anything.
I mean, you had such
an array of them
that I was wondering
if they're dangerous,
whether they're further
out than people surf?
- My experience with
sharks is that--
in order to do
shark photography,
you have to bait them
in close, to be honest.
And I have had lots of
experiences with sharks.
They're not like
mad predators that
are just erratically moving.
There are dangerous places
to be, in that they're places
where they could get confused.
They could be in water
that's shallow, that's murky,
where they're looking
for other prey,
and make accidental attacks.
I think most of them are
really do what's called
like test bites on people.
But they're just big animals.
So they don't
necessarily intend to do
the damage they may be doing.
They're quite cautious,
sharks, actually.
So the answer to your
question is, yes, there
are some areas that I
probably wouldn't go surfing.
I'm not sure I would surf
right next to the beaches
where all the seals
are in Chatham, right?
But I would surf
in other places.
And I think that the challenge
is not putting yourself
in an area where
there's likely to be
some of those dangerous
moments in there.
But I will say that one thing
that I really want to reiterate
is that they're, typically,
very cautious in the way
that they approach.
They're not just coming in
hot from around the corner
and flying in towards you.
Quite honestly, I
don't even think
you'd know they were
coming towards you.
Because they would come in from
another side, or another angle,
or something like that.
But I would say to most
people, do not worry.
The chance of
encountering them--
I never see them when I'm not
looking for them, virtually.
But be careful in the areas
that they know are trouble,
I guess is how I'd phrase that.
Yup?
- [INAUDIBLE] The high
speed shots of the fish,
you said the camera tracked--
- Not the camera, me.
We had to track with it.
- OK.
How did you keep the frame from
showing the movement of this?
- Yeah, great question.
So it's on a tripod.
And you would pan
and tilt with it.
And if the movement was
too erratic or too quick,
you would see that, actually.
But it's on a very fluid head.
So it's a very smooth
transition like this.
And the movement isn't so great.
You're not like whipping it up
in that kind of speed there.
- You're actually
doing it [INAUDIBLE].
- You have to do it manually.
And quite honestly, the
other thing you have to do
is you have to adjust
focus manually.
Because as it changes, its
focus changes, as well.
So if you're shooting something
small with a macro lens,
you have to be in rhythm
shooting, panning,
and focusing all in real time.
And it's confusing.
Because you can't over
or under focus wrong.
Because you will see that.
In slow motion, it becomes
extremely obvious to you
that you're off.
So a little mistake in
there makes big differences.
And I can only say that it
came with lots of practice.
We spent lots of time.
We made lots of
mistakes doing this.
- Thank you so much
for the footage.
It's fantastic.
I wanted to ask you whether
you would speak a little bit
about what you might
have seen, in terms
of the impact of climate
change at various sites
that I'm assuming you visited
multiple times over the course
of the last few years.
In my own experience on
expeditions to Great Barrier
Reef, things have changed--
in terms of three years,
since 2013, multiple
bleaching events.
What have you seen?
What has struck you?
- Well, I can tell you
this, that everywhere you
go in the ocean, the
timing is off now.
If the things are
migrations of this time,
if the seas are supposed
to be like this,
it's all off sync
a little bit now.
We have seen that a lot of--
not always the mass bleaching
events that you see everywhere.
But there are
definitely bleaching
of coral everywhere you
go, definitely the seas--
in the Caribbean, it's hard
to find a Caribbean reef that
is healthy.
The only place I've ever been in
the Caribbean that's beautiful
is in Limones
National Marine Park,
which is a park there that
still has the gorgeous elkhorn
coral and beautiful.
Looks like what a reef look
like ages ago in the Caribbean.
The problems are the
obvious, that climate change
is a real issue.
The overfishing and the
fishing are real problems.
And in places like
in the Philippines,
the truth is that, as
the populations increase,
the people who have
to go fish there,
they have to take
these little boats,
and go further and
further out to sea.
And you might say,
well, it's not so
bad to go further out to sea.
But really, the implication
of further out to sea for them
is that there are
squalls every day in 3:00
or 4:00 o'clock
in the afternoon.
And so those pushing
the distances
are make the pushing
coming back to land
a real challenge for them.
And so in Madagascar, we saw
the start of climate change,
of real bleaching.
But I wasn't there in
Australia to see that.
And in the Phoenix Islands
they also had to have had some.
- Thanks for the talk.
I'm curious, how
long do you typically
spend underwater
at one time on one
of these photography
expeditions?
And what is it that limits
the duration of those?
Is it the amount of
air you have available?
Or is it, in cold water, maybe
just a temperature issue?
- That's a great question.
I would spend as long
underwater as I possibly can.
I'm limited by air is a factor.
Temperature is also,
but to a less extent.
You would wear enough to be
comfortable in those things.
So it's mostly your air
that you're limited by.
And sometimes, the
objective of where
you're going, like they
may say, the currents
can switch often times on you.
So a lot of places, you
are very tide dependent.
So for instance, you
may have 45 minutes.
And that's all you get.
Because once the tide and the
current switches in slack tide,
you can't hang out
there long enough.
A lot goes with depth.
If you're really
deep, you have to be
prepared to handle the
deeper deeper depths.
And that requires all sorts of
other air, and time, and stuff.
And so really, it's
a matter of being
prepared for what you
want to photograph
and being under there.
Unfortunately, the reality
is is that all the fish
like the strong currents.
Sharks stay in strong
current, because it's
convenient for them.
And so you have to
hustle through this.
And you're kicking
really fast But you're
exerting all of your energy
to stay in those places.
So you're really
only limited by what
you're prepared to be
in the conditions for.
- You mentioned the Limones
Park in the Caribbean.
Where is that located?
- Not far from Cancun,
ironically, of all places, huh?
- We probably can take
about three more questions.
- Have you done any
photography in colder waters,
like Northern waters at all?
And what kind of sea life
would you expect there?
- I haven't been to the
Arctic, or Antarctic.
And I haven't been to any of
those under ice conditions.
That's on my future list of
places to go and things to do.
But I would say
the coldest water
that I've been diving in
is really locally here.
Quite honestly, it gets
pretty cold under there.
At the surface it could
be like 60 and 50.
But if you go down to 50
feet, 100 feet, 150 feet,
that temperature can
drop to 40 degrees.
And at 40 degrees
and 50 degrees,
it's pretty cold under there.
And I can tell you
that you know you're
cold when you have to move
the arms of your strobes,
and you don't want
to move your own arm
for fear of being colder.
- OK, maybe two more questions.
This one over here.
Two over here.
- I was curious what, if
any, advances in photography
have come about and made
your work easier, and any
that you would hope for?
Because we work in the deep sea.
And seawater attenuates light.
So unless we have Jim Cameron
with us, we can only see.
- Well, the cameras are
changing fast and very rapidly.
And the sensors
are becoming pretty
sensitive to a wide range
and spectrum of light.
I think, obviously, you want
more sensitivity to light.
And you want to work with light.
That's the two main things
you're always looking for.
I think it's not an
easy question to answer.
But I think that
range is what's there.
What I can tell you from an art
and a photography perspective,
as I see these cameras
becoming more simple,
as I see Jobs' dream
of everyone who
can take a picture
with their iPhone,
and gets these
incredible shots now,
you see that the
power of photography
is really the illusion
of photography,
and really capturing that image
the way you envision it to be.
And all that these other
cameras do, in many instances,
is they capture these moments
really quite beautifully.
Because the difference
between light
inside and outside
is very different,
and can be really
hard to photograph.
And if you ask me to do
that, I might spend all day
setting that kind of shot up.
And now these cameras do that
very effortlessly, very easily.
But what they lack
is in the ability
is how to compose the subtler
things, the motion to it,
the aperture settings.
And so in some ways,
I feel like there's
a strong education
on understanding
the appreciation and the
aesthetics of the photography
of what makes an image in
looking at those elements.
Because they, in quick
glances, get skipped over.
But in lined up, they really
become readily apparent.
And so in answering
your question,
I mean, I hope the innovations
of this technology moves
forward tremendously,
more sensitivity to light,
and better lighting,
and lights that
can go deeper, and stay
longer would be great.
- One last question.
I think it was over here.
- Hi, Keith, thanks
for doing the talk.
And it was great to
see more of your work.
What I was wondering
is how marine debris
might have impacted your work
and your experience with it?
Because I've heard stories
from some photographers where
they have to physically
move things out of the way
before they take the
shot to make it--
- You mean, like the trash would
be there that you're moving--
- Yeah, and plastic pollution
beings so prevalent.
- I guess people do
those kind of things.
That's not really the style of
the photography that I do do.
But I will say that
what I do notice
a lot is a lot of marine
debris in the water.
And what you notice
a lot with that
is actually animals sometimes
adapting to using them.
In open water
conditions, they provide
shelter for a lot of things.
And it's really sad.
You see these plastic trash
cans drifting through the--
not trash bags, just
like plastic trash
in a bag just drifting.
And you'll see sort
of fish hanging out
near those kinds of things.
And it's really amazing to see.
But I think after storms,
especially in remote beaches,
we would go through,
and you see lots
of trash, lots of
plastic that are
just up on the beach at
the high tide mark that
come in a couple of days later
after those types of things.
And it's really quite
sad that it's not there,
or removed, or--
- OK, so let's
thank Keith again.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]